[Música]
hay expectativa ante el cambio que
supondrá la compra de twitter por el
multimillonario el más desde la compañía
aseguran que no está claro lo que va a
ocurrir una vez que finalice la
operación de compra y esquemas pagará
unos 44 mil millones de dólares por esta
red social pero cuáles son las
implicaciones que pasará con las
políticas actuales de la compañía en
cuanto a la libertad de expresión lo
vamos a analizar y para ello entonces
quiero saludar en este momento a samil
stefan sido de texto cetera y consultor
de transformación digital gracias a mí
por estar nuevamente con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 también nos
acompaña en esta mesa de trabajo nuestra
periodista económica daniel hablando con
daniela hola raúl pues sí quedan muchas
dudas estoy segura de que el tiempo no
va a ser ni siquiera suficiente para
resolver todas estas dudas que nos
quedan así de samil quiero empezar
preguntándole entonces qué va a pasar
con twitter cuando se finalice este
pacto de compra por parte del
multimillonario el hongos porque tanta
expectativa entre pues los mercados
bursátiles y también los usuarios esta
red social que es prácticamente todo el
mundo
yo creo que buenos días para todos yo lo
principal es saber que el twitter sale
de la bolsa twitter deja de ser digamos
propiedad de un grupo importante de
inversionistas y pasa a ser propiedad de
una persona que va a tener como
complicamos control completo de
decisiones que se pueden tomar desde el
punto de vista técnico desde el punto de
vista operativo pero sobre todo desde el
punto de vista de temas como el que
mencionamos al comienzo de la moderación
la libertad de expresión etcétera
etcétera entonces son más las preguntas
que tenemos en este momento que las
respuestas que podemos esperar o que
podemos ya comenzar a dilucidar bueno es
importante también aclararles a los
televidentes que esta es una operación
que no se ha cerrado todavía faltan
muchas cosas autorizaciones
autorizaciones regulatorias hay una
asamblea de accionistas que también
tiene que aprobar está este negocio cómo
está el panorama de aquí allá teniendo
en cuenta también que en la comisión
europea a raúl le cuento que dijo que es
una empresa que de todas maneras tiene
que ceñirse a las reglas que hay sobre
la democracia y
este tema
daniela mencionados dos temas que son el
por importante el primero digamos la
parte económica de transaccional y
financiera la verdad es que la oferta de
54 dólares con 20 centavos es una oferta
generosa para una red social que no ha
crecido en usuarios no ha crecido en
ingresos y cuyo precio de la acción
digamos no se ha movido mucho en los
últimos años entonces yo no preveo que
veamos muchos inversionistas que digan
no estoy dispuesto a comprar a vender a
54 dólares es un premium casi del
38 por ciento con el valor que tenía la
acción el primero abril que fue el día
que lo nos compró el 9 por ciento la
compañía entonces ese pedazo tomará
tiempo pero seguramente pasará ahora con
respecto al tema de la comisión europea
creo que ahí es donde va a venir gran
parte de la discusión y es hasta donde
una persona puede tomar las decisiones
de una red social tan grande tan
poderosa y tan influyentes especialmente
en regiones como eeuu europa
samir porque el afán de lemos es
entonces si es una red social que
prácticamente no hay ingresos de
comprarla para digamos a manejar y
controlar esta información y también
quiero mejor si se puede comparar a
facebook bueno el grupo meta digamos o
con twitter que también está a manos de
una persona digamos mark zuckerberg cuál
es la diferencia de que el un box sea el
único dueño de twitter contrameta
y ese es un buen comentario y es si
marcha atrás el presidente de metas el
cio del grupo si las acciones de marchar
ver que tienen tienen más poder de voto
que las demás pero al final del día por
lo menos la mayoría de la gente lo que
ve en el mercado en el caso de meta de
facebook y demás es que hay un un bol de
brai vectors hay una una estructura
digamos de accionistas múltiples de la
bolsa y en este caso lo que termina
pasando es que los millones de
accionistas que tiene hoy twitter van a
vender sus acciones y le van a mente las
acciones a una única persona entonces el
el primer tema digamos en donde creo que
se está generando esas preocupaciones
cuando ya no es sólo que el sitio tiene
poder sino que el inversionista y dueño
te ha hecho tal vez la segunda tercera
red social más grande pero seguramente
la más influyente del planeta ahí es
donde están las preocupaciones y piensen
por ejemplo en este escenario y lo en
tiene intereses económicos en chile por
el tema
de los minerales que utiliza para para
sus baterías tiene intereses económicos
en china tiene intereses económicos en
alemania tiene intereses económicos en
eeuu donde tiene un contrato inmenso con
la nasa que pasa cuando estos gobiernos
empiecen a presionarlo a él como dueño
único de esta red social para ciertas
cosas o para que ciertas cosas pasen en
twitter a cambio de mantenerle las
prebendas contratos y demás de sus otros
negocios en esos países yo creo que esas
tal vez una de las preguntas más
importantes que hay hoy sobre la mesa
claro antes de hacer la siguiente
pregunta quiero añadir un comentario y
es que alumnos que depende mucho de
china para producir sus autos de lujo
eléctricos entonces lo que se preguntaba
hoy jeff bezos que era el anterior
multimillonario más rico del mundo lo
que se ha preguntado jazz tendrá china
de pronto algo que ver después o podrá
verse beneficiada con esta compra y la
pregunta entonces ahora viene desde el
punto de vista ya técnico y es bien el
desarrollo de nuevas funciones se le
preguntó a los usuarios que si querían
un botón de editar y eliminar los bots o
los robots que actúan como personas que
desafíos y en él en este caso específico
hay varios que son interesantes el
primero el tema de los tan bots es algo
en lo que todo el mundo en la industria
venido trabajando durante años y cada
vez sigamos son más sofisticados
entonces cada vez es más difícil
controlarlo ojalá lo logre porque en la
medida en que tengamos interacciones
entre personas creo que por lo menos
podemos bajarle el volumen a la
desinformación el segundo y el más
importante y creo yo que tiene que ver
precisamente con esas nuevas
funcionalidades no tanto de si editaron
o editar la posibilidad de dictar o
comentar un tweet pero si pensando hacia
futuro ayer con el anuncio la acción de
tesla cayó pero el precio de descuento
subió porque porque muchos de los
seguidores de demos que han invertido en
esa cripto moneda ven la posibilidad de
empezar a ver interacciones de cripto
moneda al interior de la red social por
ejemplo para temas de pagos
transnacionales etcétera etcétera
entonces lo que vemos es un interés
clarísimo de él desde el punto de vista
técnico pero la duda que tenemos detrás
es que hay detrás de él por lo menos de
la discusión o de la disculpa de la
libertad de expresión que fue en
realidad la razón por la cual un día
puso un pidió oiga debería haber
libertad de expresión para poder que la
democracia funcione entonces voy a
comprar sí y creo que ahí es donde
quedan las grandes preocupaciones desde
el punto de vista técnico seguramente
veremos grandes avances que durante los
últimos años vemos también no hay vuelta
atrás en esta compra de en mos a twitter
y también le quiero preguntar algo pues
yo lo comparo también lo que pasó con
wasabi todas las políticas de seguridad
en su momento que muchísima gente empezó
a migrar a telegram con este miedo que
puede haber de algunos usuarios de la
red social twitter puede haber otra red
social que le puedo hacer algún tipo de
competencia a twitter en unos días o en
una semana o en unos meses o ya existe
esa red social es esa es una gran
pregunta por dos razones la primera es
que lo natural sería pensar en una red
social que esté creciendo que sea súper
activa y entonces todo el mundo pensaría
en tick tock sí pero entonces saldrán
los puristas que dicen no es que tipo
que es de una compañía china y entonces
el gobierno chino y volveremos a esta
discusión alrededor de quienes son los
dueños y hasta donde están amarrados a
ciertos gobiernos etcétera etcétera pero
seguramente lo que veremos es más
personas o más entidades pensando en que
si esto puede ocurrir con twitter es la
posibilidad de lanzar nuevas cosas vimos
y creo que lo hablamos hace unos meses
con ustedes el tema de tweets sois en la
red social de donuts aunque no ha
despegado que sigue perdiendo plata que
técnicamente no funciona pero que además
pareciera estar muerta ahora será que
con esto gana algo de velocidad será que
vemos nuevas redes sociales en salir o
será que vemos un resurgimiento de
facebook y de instagram en un plano en
el que habían queda un poquito relegados
en ese concepto digamos del de la cuadra
de discusiones
pública de discusiones y será que vemos
eso por ahora todavía falta a ver si
esto pasa y qué tanto impacto puede
llegar a family se le pregunté por qué
hasta yo lo pensé yo digo sí yo lo pensé
que no estoy porque yo creo en el
negocio pues obviamente gente que está
involucrada ya más que pensaba y seguro
ya está lista no da ni claro que sí no y
lo otro también que yo pienso es bueno
él es el hombre más rico del mundo pero
tampoco es que tenga mucho dinero en su
bolsillo
samir tiene que financiar lo que pasa es
que claro y esto salió financiado y creo
que la preocupación de los
inversionistas de pedra fue precisamente
esto esto sale financiado la mitad la
decisión viene financiada por bancos
norteamericanos que seguramente están
soportadas con sus acciones de este test
la por eso es que la acción destaca yo